M it's
God it's
God because it's late we're going to
have to keep it short I would have liked
to have a longer debate with Avery but
the previous debates took you know
pretty long so hopefully we get this is
a fruitful conversation we'll get a lot
out of it uh
so hello yeah yeah try talk right right
there yeah there you go oh okay all
right he's tired job so bear with them
yeah yeah yeah it's way past my bedtime
anyway Cur man
curfew um so the position or the
question that I'm that's going to be
asked is is Jesus God according to the
scripture and if we look at Exodus 6:4
it says here o Israel your lord your God
is one
is Deuteronomy 64
Baba he said Exodus he's sleeping guys I
told you I'm I'm tired bear with me man
we know what you meant we know what you
me I'm sure it's in it's in deuteron
yeah yeah 64 I'm sorry all right so we
also have and this is the main point
that I'm going to ask Avery in numbers
239 it
says I I am I am God and I am not a man
God is not a man that he should lie oh
I'm sorry yes God is not a man that he
should lie Li nor is he the son of man
that he should
Repent Jesus in the New Testament in the
gospels refers to himself as the son of
man 81 times so if if the Jesus said I
have not come to abolish the law but to
fulfill it so you can't look at the Old
Testament and say that's no longer
applicable in numbers 23:19 God says I
am not a man God is not a man that he
should lie nor is the son of man that he
should repent again Jesus said he is the
son of man over 81 times in the gospels
so now my question to Avery is you
believe that Jesus is God but it clearly
says that the son of man cannot be God
so what is your response got you so it
doesn't say that the son of man can't be
God it just says that God is not a man
that he lies nor is he a son of man that
he repents or changes his mind so it's
talking about the character of God he
doesn't lie like man does nor does he
change his mind like man does he's notle
and if you read a couple veres befor
there somebody is asking for God to
destroy Israel and so this is the
response cuz he Pro he promised to keep
Israel and preserve them so he's not
going to destroy them which would mean
he's going back on his word and he's a
liar and he's fickle like human beings
so he's not a man that he should lie nor
is he a son of man that he changes his
mind now if God were to become a man we
would expect that he's a man that
doesn't lie if he is a son of man we
would expect him to be a son of man who
was consistent which is what we see in
Jesus he never lied nor did he change
his mind or repent right so Jesus fits
the bill okay so the response to that is
is that it specifically says God is not
a son of man that that God is not a son
of man so the specific that that he
should repent but the spec uh the
specific example that's given doesn't
negate the the general uh uh idea that's
been giv been given here which is God Is
Not the son of man so the specificity
hold on hold on the specificity doesn't
negate the general rule the general rule
is God Is Not the son of man God is not
a man God is not a son of man just
because he uses an example doesn't mean
it negates the actual meaning of what
that is it's it's a definitive statement
let me respond to that so he doesn't say
that God is not the son of man it
doesn't say that it says God is Not a
son of man that he changes his mind this
whole thing is about his character and
him keeping his word the whole thing
that's what the whole thing is about but
it's a description okay so let me ask
you this sure does the verse say that
God cannot be man that's an argument
from Silence it's not it's it is that's
that's a semantic fallacy that is a
logical fallacy which shows CU it's
called the argument of Silence you look
called the argument of Silence it is
because you're saying using what it said
what is used you're using you're saying
that because it says God cannot become a
man therefore he could but that's an
argument of coming from absence of
evidence you cannot use that look for
example this is in what in what time is
this verse brought out and who's the
prophet at the time remind me Moses okay
yes so do Christians believe that God
was a man in Moses's
time they no no right so he became a man
in the first century he took on flesh
this is why this is important when it
says that God is not a man that he lies
you're trying to say well see God is not
a man Jesus is a man so therefore he's
God he's not God we're not saying that
God was a man in Moses's time this is
something that happened in the future so
this is why I asked you okay does it say
that God cannot become man again that's
an argument for silence you can't have
the absence of evidence be evidence I'll
give you an example does it say God
can't become a horse does it say God
can't become a fly does it all the
there's so many things you could say
from the absence of evidence but you
have to provide the evidence when
talking about scripture for who God is
so again just because God uses an
example uh according to his Essence in
nature doesn't mean that you could say
okay now he can become this now he
become that because he didn't say that
he can't well so no so it's not an it's
not an argument from Silence this is why
you won't answer the question because
you know where this is going you know
that it doesn't say that it's a logical
fallacy let me land this you're you're
that's the scapegoat saying that it's a
logical fallacy it doesn't answer the
question question it doesn't say that
God cannot become a man so that's it say
that it also doesn't say God can become
anything else well hold on to second now
so you you're saying bring the evidence
of the contrary so I'm not using I'm not
I'm not all you had to do is ask me man
where does it say that God can become a
man that's all you had to do was ask me
that Isaiah 9:6 For unto us a child is
born unto us a son is given and his name
Shall be Called wonderful counselor
Mighty God Everlasting father Prince of
Peace so it says that God is is is
coming glad you brought that up what are
the four what are the four four names
that he should be called wait wait wait
no you brought up Isaiah 119 question
this wait wait wait yes but it's very
important that you brought this up yeah
I asked question when was he ever called
Mighty God wonderful counselor
Everlasting father Eng with the question
are you but but it's you're the one who
brought it up and I asked a question and
the question but you can't skim over
that you you trying to we do one at a
time sure go okay so my question was on
this when it says that the son right is
the Mighty God according to this verse
it identifies that the son is God
correct no okay so who's the Mighty God
according to the
verse whoever Emanuel is but it's not
Jesus it doesn't say Emanuel no doesn't
say because listen and I'll tell you why
it's not Jesus because there were four
names that this specific Emmanuel
whoever this Emanuel character is
supposed to be called hold on you
insinuated that it's supposed to be
Jesus that's not what I said you said I
need you to focus focus okay who is who
is focus no no F Focus the son it says
is the Mighty God
correct just read the verse okay I'll
read it again for unto us a child is
born okay unto us a son is given and the
government shall be upon his shoulder
and his name Shall be Called wonderful
counselor the Mighty God father of
Eternity Prince of Peace correct who's
the Mighty God according to the verse so
none of those titles were ever given to
Jesus who's the Mighty God none of those
titles were ever given to Jesus way is
the son the Mighty God according to the
verse in the yeah whoever is it's
referring to butm butm says ye are gods
and ye are all sons of the most high and
refers hold on hold on hold on hold on
I'm not shuffling I'm not
shuffling God so what is the word for
God that's used not a Muslim Shuffle
it's not a Muslim Shuffle Psalms 826
says I said ye are gods and you are all
sons of the most high so there were they
were called in the Old Testament but
with a lowercase Jeep but they weren't
Yahweh well you know what that's no give
up that's a beautiful Point you're close
man you're close Okay that people that
there are there are many beings that are
called these Gods with a lowercase G in
in a sense but they're not identified as
Yahweh which is interesting because when
we go to the very next chapter Isaiah 10
we read verse 20 and 20 and and 21 it
says that Israel shall return to Yahweh
they shall return to the Mighty God so
who's the ACC to ACC so do you know
actually in Isaiah 42 it identifies who
the suffering Ser wait can I just speak
this is about theant but but this is
what the prophecy is talking about
Isaiah 42 when you talk when you're
talking about no I'm talking about Isa
Isaiah
119 Mighty God Everlasting father none
of these titles were ever given to Jesus
but these these prophecies are given are
said that these are talking about Jesus
Isaiah 10 ver 20 21 it says that Israel
shall return to Yahweh The Remnant shall
return to the Mighty God in in Isaiah 10
who is Israel returning
to I don't know who I just said it okay
I don't want don't do leading questions
just say your say your point I'm trying
to hand say your point no because I
don't agree I'm not going to agree with
what your interpretation all we got to
do is read what do we do here y'all we
just we just read man okay so make your
point and I make your point I'm not
going to ask you leading question
that's how we do things okay well that's
not how
I is returning to yway the Mighty God
according to that verse who's the Mighty
God I'm not doing this leading question
stuff just say your point and then and
then
Contin come just just make your point
and then I'll I'll answer this because
this is my point I I can't just give it
to you and be like you I need you I need
you I need us to be on the same on the
same you know you know you listen I this
is leading you can just say your point
without my particip according to the
verse it says that Israel is returning
to Yahweh the Mighty God who's the
Mighty God according to the verse tell
me Yahweh right do we agree just
continue with your point I'm not going
to agree for for me to continue I need
us to agree I'm not going to play tag
along it's not playing look it's for
it's for honest conversation just make
your point see if I just give how did we
get wait hold on how did we get from
numbers 23:19 to this question how do we
get that's a little Christian Shuffle
that you're doing we were talking about
numbers
239 and then now we're we're going all
over Isaiah let's stick to numbers 2319
come here he asked what does this have
to do with numbers 23:19 he says in
numbers 2319 it Deni my brother my
brother relax numbers
23:19 right you brought this up saying
God is not a man that he should lie nor
son of man can't change his mind the
reason why I took you to Isaiah 9 and is
and Isaiah 10 because I asked you does
the verse negate that God can become man
in the first place the answer to that is
no it doesn't say that he can't become
man so that's what I'm you said well
you're you're arguing from Silence so
I'm showing you biblically that the
scripture says that God will become man
that's the whole point of that so Hosea
11:9 says I am God and not a man again
God describes who he is that
changes he says he doesn't change
oh my
God don't let him ruin this I I just
wanted to ask real quickly the word
that's oh sorry my apologies so the two
verses that were mentioned uh about
Israel returning to Yahweh the Mighty
God oh sorry and um the one of numbers
20 23:19 do these both use the same word
for God uh with the Hebrew well well
well yeah the the word is l right the L
the Hebrew word is l for God do you
happen to know the verse I I I don't
blame you if you don't know the ver in
Hebrew do you believe it's you me you
mean for me to recite it in Hebrew well
no yeah like do you do you happen to
know like what the last the word the
word is elgore and Isaiah 996 and Isaiah
10:21 L God and gior is mighty right the
okay so it's the same word within
numbers
239 it just says God is not a man so I
think it's Elohim in that one Elohim is
not a man that he should lie nor is he
sen CH so how do we how do we know we're
it's referring to the same it says
Elohim huh so how do we know it's
referring to the same God cuz we do know
God can be different words within the
Hebrew within the Greek whatever oh yeah
just because it's a different word being
used based on like it's uh it's a part
of speech it doesn't change the identity
of the person so the the in numbers 2319
is talking about Yahweh right and he's
asking yah say earlier in the verses yes
and also later but it doesn't say it in
that sentence not in that it just says
God is not a man that that that lies nor
is he a son of man that changes his mind
well then I have to look at the the
usage cuz sometimes within like for
example in the New Testament curios the
word that's used sometimes for Jesus is
also used for like land owners for
people who like you know have a place of
business like I have to know if the word
L is used only with God or if it can be
used in different context so the word L
is just like it's a generic word in the
scripture for God that's all so it's
it's about the identity of who God is
yeah so according to the scripture is
talking about Yahweh okay can we can we
there was a good point that I wanted to
make with Isaiah I believe what 119
Mighty God isah 96 96 okay okay that he
shall be called Mighty God did you wait
did you acknowledge that the son is the
might God can I answer just let me
answer yo that's the question on the
hand you haven't answered that yet no
well um let me speak I let you speak un
uninterrupted my style my style is I go
you go that's not my sty you got to
answer questions you got got questions
no that's not how a debate works I going
to my debate style is different than
your debate style I you're exactly your
debate style requires cooperation it's
not it's not I'm not obligated to play
tag along on when you're when you're so
unfortunately look this this is hold
wait wait we're having a conversation if
I ask you if you ask me a which is what
you did you asked me a question I
answered you directly so if I ask you a
question I expect you to answer me
directly not waffle or change the
subject I'm not waffling or changing the
subject you're the one who went to
Isaiah in Isaiah 96 about when we were
talking about numbers 239 the son of the
Mighty God in Isaiah 96 okay if you're
talking about Isaiah 9:6 He Shall be
Called Mighty God Everlasting father
wonderful counselor and there was one
more uh Prince of Peace Prince of Peace
was Jesus ever called any of those four
things notice what you just did you just
you just asked me a question without
answering what I asked you but but the
question at hand here is that you're
going to eventually tell me this is
prophesizing Jesus right I don't care
about where we're going to get to are
you are you but that's the question are
you going to say this prophesies to
Jesus yes or no wait wait no answer my
question now since you want the first
one okay okay yes fine let let's say the
the sun is no it's not let's say is is
is it either is or isn't is the son the
Mighty God in Isaiah 96 in this verse
yes okay okay so according to the verse
God is going to come and be born as a
son correct
no no no no no okay
do your come back and I'll I'm done I'm
done I'll
back get away from enough with the
Antics bro just come here yo keep doing
your great work brother keep working
here bro who are
you is is
this oh
my come on man look what you
did go ahead this this is insane so it's
yes the son is the Mighty God according
to the verse so then God is going to be
born as a son right no wa wait hold on
hold on Mighty God so for example what
what is the word Israel means what does
Israel mean one who struggles with god
oh okay so just because the person has
God in his name does that necessarily
mean that they're God like Emmanuel God
With Us it's a name it doesn't
necessarily mean that that person is God
yes okay let me show you the difference
the difference between Israel and
Emmanuel Israel is one who struggles
with God not God who struggles so it's
is it's one who struggles with God so
both of the L's are at the end of the
word emmanu because God because God is
in there so it struggles with God so
Emmanuel is god with us but no no no no
no but that's in English that's not in
the Hebrew you just ask me what it means
we're breaking it down I know but I'm
saying you're trying to say that it it's
the reverse with Emanuel but it's this
way with Israel because that's the name
so and so now especially El gior is the
Mighty God the person's name is the
Mighty God not that God is mighty that's
what I'm showing you the difference is
in some of these names it attributes to
God like for example if you talk about
all of them are titles like Abdullah is
the servant of Allah talk but it's the
same thing just because it has the name
go of God in it doesn't mean that person
is necessarily God I'm giv you another
example Israel is struggles with God
Ishmael is God hears yes God who yeah
God hears so not that he's not he's he's
not being identified as God but Emanuel
the person is being called God With Us
uh elgore the person is called The
Mighty God do you see the difference no
so in these other names these are
attributes and Praises that's giving
glory to God with these with Emmanuel
and elgore it's identifying God himself
trying to take that difference no it's
not no it's not how you know that how do
I know that because these are names ask
any rabinal scholar when a name of God
when when a name of God is hold on when
a
when the name of God is in the when the
name of God is in a person's name that
that person necessarily has the uh
essence of God what it means you're
right not all the time which I just give
not ever not all the time that nobody
says not ever see I just gave you two
examples Emmanuel and elgore is is
referring to the essence of God himself
okay so let me what is your reputation
to that wait is G you never answered my
question is Jesus wait wait wait is
Jesus ever called Mighty God Prince of
Peace wonderful counselor uh Everlasting
father I'm not shifting that you're
saying this is this prophecy is about
Jesus correct yet he was never called
any of these names so how could it be
Jesus okay so notice here the Muslim
Shuffle it's not the shuffle just answer
the question was he ever called Mighty
God was he ever called wonderful
counselor was he ever called Everlasting
father no he wasn't where yes that's
modalism so you guys don't even know
what modalism yes it is it's to say the
son becomes the Father the father
becomes the son we know what that means
well actually the word is abiad in the
Hebrew which is father of Eternity ABI
father odd eternity so wait let me do
come on manad goe go all right
appreciate it so this is what this is
the part that I'm saying that you're
running away from you keep trying to run
away from the question that I asked you
to get to your argument and I have no
problem addressing it Samir you know me
I have no problem answer in your
question first let's K me off his stream
right unless he kicked me off his stream
three times Sam times Samir is to New
York to to debate this Stu Samir doesn't
have as much swag as he does online you
know here like here here here he's more
like you know personable you know I love
him actually but okay but um so look
here's the point I asked you the
question before you asked the question
of was he ever called these names the
question is that we need to solidify
okay is is God being born as a ACC to
the okay you say no so this is why we
can't move forward because we need to
establish this you said you admitted
that the sun is identified as the Mighty
God you the Mighty God used Mighty God
or elabore is used to describe prophets
and God hold on wait wait wait wa let me
continue let me continue in Psalms 826
we going to be stuck here when Psalms
826 When God Says ye are gods and ye are
all sons of the most high El correct so
when it says that someone will be called
Mighty God it doesn't mean they're
ontologically God or Yahweh it's just
it's just they have the name El Gabor
see this this is the problem I you
didn't even listen to what I asked you
what was so I I I brought you to the
very next chapter that identifies Yahweh
as the Mighty God it says Yahweh is the
Mighty God so the the chapter prior I I
would have to look into it okay so
Isaiah chapter 9 I'm sorry Isaiah 10
verse 20 and 21 Israel is going to
return to Yahweh the Mighty God okay no
one is identified in in the entire Bible
as the Mighty God except for yahwe okay
correct all right now okay fine let's
let's go with that what in order to
qualify Jesus as being this the person
in this prophecy then he has to be have
called Everlasting father Mighty God uh
wonderful counselor and Prince of Peace
he was never called any of those things
ever okay and you know that all right so
and this crowd do fact check it go find
someone find me in the gospels where
Jesus has called any of those four names
got you all right so to respond to you
now goad so now that we know that Yahweh
is the Mighty God and it says that the
son is the Mighty God then who does that
make the son okay I'm I get what you're
saying so answer it say no no no no
no I have I need I need you to say it if
Yahweh is the Mighty God and it says the
son is the Mighty God then who is the
son come on I'm going to listen do it
just continue with your point man why
answer me on
this continue with your point continue
with your point this is the point I I
can't continue because there could be a
difference between be be being called
Mighty God and the Mighty God I have to
look I have to I would have to look I
would have to look and do my research so
I can't concede to I can't concede to
that point but continue could you just
make your point all right so so until
you do further research where we're at
because again you're quoting scripture
that I'm not necessarily familiar with
then what you doing I no no no no no I
could only speak on what I know and what
I do know is that in that particular
prophecy in that particular prophecy he
was never called any of those four
things so can anyone pull up a verse
where Jesus was called Mighty God
wonderful counselor Everlasting father
or Prince of Beast okay okay so so so so
he was called none of those things do we
agree cuz you know the scripture No we
don't so he was called there where yeah
hold on before we get there cuz I'm not
going to let you Shuffle off you know me
I'm not shuffling off I'm dealing with
the bir I have I have like a like like a
OCD like I get a twitch when somebody
tries to shuffle off like it really
affects I don't even dance what are you
talking
about I
confir so look so if if we're just being
logical now let's say at least you don't
you're not uh you're not going to agree
to this but the logic follows at least
just let me with this that the logic
follows follow that if the mighty since
the Mighty God is Yahweh and the son is
the Mighty God then logic follows that
the son is Yahweh can you at least agree
to that that logic that's logical okay
let's go with that I'm not agreeing to
that but I said just for argument sake
no not for argument sake does that
logically no no I'm not going to put my
name under that so just continue because
again I have to I have to do the
research for myself we're reading a
translation at the end of again well
this is going off your I can't conce
okay you can if you're honest can we
listen yes
if we if we are talking about this verse
can you please show me where he was
called any of those four things why
can't you why can't you show me I just
told you why cuz I have OCD because you
keep trying to change the
subject I I don't know my answer to that
is I don't know you don't know all right
let's do it
again Yahweh is the Mighty God the son
is the Mighty God so that means the son
is fill in the blank the Mighty God the
Mighty God which
is Yahweh oh get it do you get it I know
you get it Samir you're smart you're not
dumb
okay let me ask you the question one
more
time I what if wait wait wait wait I'm
admitting wait hold on I'm admitting I
have to do more research on these two
verses so I have to see it in context
why would I conceit to something that
I'm I'm clearly saying I don't know so
how about this until you do more
research on this then we move on then
let's move let's let's move on but you
can't ask me anything else on Isaiah 96
fine fine fine okay fine we then then
we'll come back to it on a later time
maybe on a live if you don't kick me
off was kind of
CRA is that Instagram wait what is that
yeah where' that come from IA so so yeah
do you have something else okay I
actually have quite a few okay so in
Mark 10:18 is it okay if I ask a
question let me finish is everything
okay wait wait wait wait what do you
want to ask up into yeah yeah like
noises keep cominging I want to ask you
about the we'll get to that we'll get to
that okay wait wait wait wait we'll save
that for the end I promise I'm not going
to leave until we deal with the Nel deal
okay okay okay okay it's like a baby
with a
lollipop that is my lollipop is my
lollipop all right so in Mark 10:18
right the rich man comes you you you're
very familiar everybody call the yeah I
guess the rich man says good teacher
what shall I do to to inherit eternal
life Jesus says why do you call me good
there is none good but God Alone Now
Avery may come back and say well he
wasn't trying to deny that he was good
but rather he was trying to bring his
attention to the fact that he was
calling him good but this doesn't work
because in the very next couple verses
the man drops the title good and simply
calls him teacher so he understood that
Jesus wasn't good in the same way that
God is good and he only calls him
teacher and then what does it say
afterwards Jesus loved him so Jesus
loving him is approving of him dropping
the title good it doesn't say that yes
he does it says that Jesus looked at him
and loved him yes it does read the verse
no
one you're going to make me get it out
bro you're saying that it says that
Jesus loved him for dropping the title
no no it said Jesus looked at him and
loved him after he said that okay I got
you all right I'm going to deny that it
says that okay I I you still want me to
pull it up no you don't have
to cuz you're right it does say that it
does say that right why do you call me
good Jesus answered no one is good
except God alone you know the
Commandments you shall not murder you
shall not commit adultery you shall not
steal you shall not give false testimony
you shall not defraud honor your father
and mother teacher he declared all these
things I kept since a boy Jesus looked
at him and loved him right so notice the
um the continuity of when Jesus looked
at him and love him it wasn't the first
time he called him teacher or dropped
the title good right because at first he
said you know good teacher how do I get
saved or whatever how inherit interal
interal eternal life eternal life and
Jesus asked him why do you call me good
there's nothing good but God alone then
he he drops the title good and says well
teacher ask him the same thing it
doesn't say right after that Jesus
looked at him with love and then told
him it was after he said I've done these
things since my youth right then Jesus
said then it says Jesus looked at him
with love and said then give your give
your possessions there's one thing you
lack give your possessions to the poor
then come follow me okay so the question
is why did the man understand and say
and dro the title good I would say that
he didn't understand I would but Jesus
didn't correct him Jesus said why do you
call me good there is none good but God
alone and the man understood him correct
correctly and he simply called him
teacher so if God is only good and Jesus
is not a good teacher rather he's a
teacher and Jesus didn't reprimand him
for dropping the title therefore Jesus
cannot be God and I have more proofs
besides just this verse but let's go off
of that so why did the man drop the
title good well I would say that he
actually misunderstood what Jesus was
doing because Jesus was testing him and
saying and asking him does he know the
implications of what he's calling him if
he's calling him good then he's
recognizing that he's God was he ready
for that and clearly he wasn't that's
why he dropped the title no because if
he drops the title he wouldn't he if he
if he recognized that he was God he
would have kept calling him good teacher
well exactly so he simply called teacher
he didn't recognize that he was God he
missed it so let me ask you this that's
but that's your that's you superimposing
your interpretation on it if you read
the text you're superimposing that Jesus
is not good that he's denying to be good
he is denying to be good okay in what
way is Jesus not good that God is go cuz
God is perfect
and Jesus cursed the Fig Tree the the
innocent fig tree when it was out of SE
what do it say that that's wrong to do
what do you mean what does it say is
wrong to do why would you curse a fig
tree that had never committed any sin
that just well actually this is
interesting okay so the Fig Tree
actually was dressed with leaves so
according to fig trees they actually
when they have when they show leaves
they actually have early fruit okay that
is ready to be be picked that's called
braber fuit so when it has leaves that
means it has that early fruit this
particular fig tree had leaves but it
didn't have the fruit so it had the
appearance of being fruitful but it
really wasn't and that was an
illustration of Israel hold on that was
an illustration of Israel and the
Pharisees they looked Godly and they had
the appearance of godliness but they
bore no fruit so that was an
illustration to the Disciples of Israel
of how Godless they were and how
fruitless they were and that means that
God will curse them if they continue in
that way that's the whole point of the
Fig well all right I understand what
you're saying but in this sense God uh
is is perfect that's is synonymous with
good so Jesus made mistakes he Jesus for
did he hold on wait wait wait he made
Mist he forgot things what what did he
forget my Lord my Lord why have you
forsaken me wait wait when he was
supposedly on the cross where did he say
he forgot that what did he for because
supposedly he doesn't know if he's God
supposedly according to you he's
supposed to know his Divine mission
right and he's on but yet on the cross
he's looking up to the sky saying Eli
which translates from the Aramaic my God
my God why why do you why have you
forsaken me so why would God think that
that God for forsake you know that's
that's interesting cuz and by the way
we're jumping from topic to topic again
but I'm but I'm going you asked me for
an example well yeah me for an example
me an example of forgetfulness and this
didn't show that this just show he
forgot his Divine Mission The Corner
Stone of Christianity it's funny that
you say that in this verse it shows that
Jesus forgot his Divine Mission yeah
when he's quoting a Psalm that points to
his Divine
mission where do where does my God my
God where have you forsaken me where
does that come from tell me Psalm
22 yeah that's literally how Psalm 22
starts off but you want to know what
else is in there go ahead it says that
Bulls surround me they Encompass me they
mock me they say the Lord he Delights in
the Lord let him save him he's he's
beloved by the Lord let him bring him
down sound familiar that's what they
were saying to Jesus on thear with Psalm
all right no worries but also when we
get to verse 16 It also says this that
um Psalms you're talking about Psalms
Psalm 22 same Psalm it says they
Encompass me they make their mouths at
me they pierced my hands and my feet and
then in verse and then in the next verse
it says they gamble over my clothing and
for my garments they cast lots that's
John chapter 19 okay so the Roman
soldiers gambled over jesus' clothes
they pierced his hands and his feet they
mocked him and surrounded him he's
surrounded by his enemies Jesus is
literally this was Psalms 22 Psalms 22
so Jesus on the cross is literally
pointing to his Divine Mission by saying
my God my God why have you forsaken me
he ain't forget nothing he's saying
y'all don't know okay fine so it's God
all knowing wait so this is this is
another thing wait hold on wait wait I
that was a great point Thank you so how
is so in what way is God good that Jesus
isn't question how is God good that
Jesus isn't yeah in what way is God good
that Jesus isn't that God knows
everything and Jesus doesn't so this is
so this is so so this is my point I'm
glad you asked that God knows everything
cuz he's perfect and Jesus doesn't know
everything because he's not perfect
because perfect entails that you you're
God because only god is perfect so let
me get let me let let me land my point
and you'll see where I'm going with this
so when he calls himself Good Shepherd
that means he's like not good hold on
hold on let me let me make my point okay
how is God perfect and Jesus is not
perfect because Jesus had limited
knowledge and God had perfect knowledge
so in Mark 13:32 amazing in Mark
13:32 let's let's go a little bit before
13:32 in Mark chap 13 what's he talking
about he was talking about the signs of
the hour he was he was saying the the
Stars shall fall the heavens shall be
cleft the under there are all these
things that are going to predicate the
hour G all these details hold on yes he
gives all these details and I'm glad you
said that he gives all these details y
and then he says but of that hour no one
knows wow not not the not the angels in
Heaven nor the son but only the father
describing Everything Jesus you're not
debating Jesus did not know when the
hour was only the father
knows so if Jesus Is God omnicient like
God how come he doesn't know when the
hour is go ahead well actually um it's
funny because when you actually go to
the Greek I like I like your Dan
I'm
exactly actually it's interesting a lot
of Muslims don't know this in the Greek
it says oh didn't no no that's not what
I'm talking about actually okay it
actually it actually says if not the
father huh not except the father it says
if not the father if you look in the
Greek and we actually pull it up uh you
was on Bible Hub right oh yeah let me
did it die I can show you it it says if
not the father if not the father that's
the first time I ever heard that
translation but only the Father in
Heaven only the father missed let me see
let me go to let's go to Bible Hub real
quick and I'll show you something yeah
I'll take a Bible Hub and then after
this can I ask about the inil yeah yeah
yeah we yeah
we I I actually one more thing and then
we'll move to the no come on man no no I
promised theel I I said I was going to
only be here for 10 minutes I got some
energy now so you know L some proof man
after this let me ask about the in jail
man
okay Mark
13:32 going to GRE text analysis right
mm we go to the Greek over here I
appreciate you guys letting me use your
phone
man yall the MVP okay so it does say if
not the father but that means only the
father it doesn't mean only the father
Yes it does it mean so outside it means
only the father outside of the father
there's no knowledge of this correct so
it's not saying that he doesn't know it
says no one knows the day or the hour
not even the angels of Heaven nor the
son of nor nor the son if not the father
so it's if it wasn't for the father no
one would know yes
no no logic no no this this is no these
are semantics say means if not it means
only the father your only answer is
nuh-uh nuh-uh
it says only the father knows when the
so I heard you and this is this is the
point I wanted to bring up you wanted to
bring up oen yes o you lied about oen
didn't you no yes what I lie about o you
said oen means to declare no it doesn't
oh really give me give me back the phone
okay let's go hold on hold on me back
I'm so
oh on man what does oen mean to declare
right me to declare to tell something no
it doesn't okay no it doesn't you sure
yep so if it if if it does can you cash
at me so I can get some ice cream
no no all right you cold for
that that's messed up
Sam samur not Samir samur sorry we we
don't need the money for the toll back
home bro come
on $20 now yeah I
know that's so okay AI overview Google
no the Greek word oin means to know or
to possess
information the word homio means to
declare or to confess idin means to know
you could all look this up on your own
phone can can you read this
paragraph strong exal I where is this
from it's the it's the Strong's
Concordance it gives you the definition
of the word and the usage strong primary
so just read that paragraph all right
properly to see literally by
implication to know be aware behold keep
going not read the paragraph I gave you
consider have knowledge look on perceive
see be sure tell understand words to do
what wait but that's that's a okay
that's a
secondary uh uh
usage mean to tell or to declare
something right you just read it no but
that but this is this we the word used
for declare is used in the Bible had
Jesus meant declare he would have it
would have used the word homio it
wouldn't have used the word you know you
know what's amazing about what you're
doing right now is that if I were to
read the Quran and I brought up a word
you would be like well you know in the
Arabic there's all these different
meanings one word can be you know used
in have 100 words in the Arabic so it's
it's similar to in Hebrew there's
multiple even in English there's
multiple words that can be used to
express mean the only problem is no
Christian scholar has ever used your
position of saying that this word
doesn't mean to know that it means to
declare you what that's actually
interesting that you say that because
actually when you look up Augustine St
St Augustine he actually interprets this
to mean that it says that the how he
uses no is to declare that's St
Augustine a church father so when you
say no well you have to look at it in
another way because you're how else are
we going to
recile but the primary
meaning primary meaning of oin means to
know okay what about then and then what
Christians will say the traditional
Christian position was would say that
this is Jesus speaking from his human
nature not from his divine nature but
that's the
interpretation even in the McCarthy
Study Bible which you recommend the mcy
study Bible you recomend that I'm not
copying but you're the one who
recommended that
sh out to man may Allah bless you come
on right there so wait wait before you
move on okay so we see how the word can
mean to tail something or to declare
right that's not the primary meaning can
we agree I didn't I don't know I don't
know this guy could put I don't know
what website this is from this is this
is Strong's Concordance so it tells you
the meanings the roots and how words are
used it's a concordance okay okay so we
see that the word can be used to declare
or to tell something right yeah but
that's not the prim meaning okay and the
way Christians understood it is not the
way that you I just quoted a church
father that understood it the same way
that I do so when we have church fathers
that understand it this way we have
Christians that understand it this way
we see the definition it can mean to
tell something or to declare it's
perfectly in line with Jesus saying no
one knows the day orir the hour nor the
son of nor the son of the Angels means
it's not for anyone to make it known to
tell it to declare it's only for the
father to do it that's his authority why
because his coming is like a Jewish
wedding if you read Matthew 22 a few
vers of chapters before a je according
to a Jewish wedding it's the father that
makes know day are you sure about that
yes I am it's the father that makes
known the wedding day I'm going to hold
you to this is being recorded they
saying that a Jewish father is
responsible for announcing the day of
the wedding making it known are you sure
yes I'm sure okay I'm going to hold you
to that all right all right so that that
answers that can I ask about the yeah oh
oh this was the last thing before we
move on no no no I said I said I had one
more thing I did say there was one more
thing I said there's one more thing I
promise we after this we'll get to the
no I
didn't that was before this now I
promise I promise when I am going to
keep my word after this point this is
what I'm going to end on this is what I
intended to end on so let me just end on
this and we'll move to the inal I
promise promise yes last last all right
I
believe all
right so my question is what is the
Cornerstone belief of Christianity it's
the death the Life Death resurrection of
Jesus Christ amen cor right that is the
Cornerstone of Christianity okay now the
prophecy that was made by Jesus was what
just as Jonah shall be in the belly of
the whale for three days and three
nights better than this hold on just as
Jonah shall be in the belly of the whale
for three days and three nights so shall
the son of man be in the belly of the
Earth for three days and three nights
now let's let's do some math here Jesus
was crucified on Friday night so he goes
into the tomb Friday night how many
nights is that one Saturday morning
that's one
day Saturday night that's two nights he
rose on
Sunday amen is he waiting on that amen I
was waiting for the Christians to say
something he rose on Sunday morning so
that's two days and two nights the
prophecy specifically
says as Jonah was in the way and you
could look this up in the Greek it says
three days and three nights Jonah was in
the belly of the whale so shall the son
of man be in the belly of the Earth for
three days and three nights or yes so
show me how is how can you believe in a
prophecy that was never fulfilled when
Jesus said it
himself I know it's a tough
one oh dude my back
listen I'm tired man all look summer so
there's multiple way samur sorry samur
there's multiple ways that Jesus
described his death burial and
Resurrection okay as as you just saw he
said three days and three nights correct
in another verse he says in 3 days
doesn't mention nights okay that's and
another verse he mentions after 3 days
MH um in Luke 24 when he appears to the
disciples um Inus I think that's how you
say it okay they say and it's the third
day that this has happened when he
appears to them and this is after he
rose resurrected okay so you have these
different uh descriptions on the third
day in 3 days after 3 days and 3 days
and three nights what do we see here
these are euphemisms that's just talking
about a three-day time span no yes it is
no it isn't no it's that's
interpretation because he said just as
let me it okay okay let me land it you
got Friday Saturday Sunday and he roll
on Sunday so that's three days that he's
in the Tomb and he rose on the third day
all of those euphemisms describing a
three-day time span there's no problem
there okay so the only problem with that
is he said he compared him being in the
belly of the earth as Jonah and this is
a specific it's not a eup euphemism it's
a specific because specifically Jonah
was in the belly of the whale for three
days and three nights it's very specific
so he said so shall the so shall the son
of man be in the belly of the Earth for
three days and three nights he
specifically said days and nights the
number of days and nights that Jonah
it's not eup euphemism he's recalling
the numbers of days and nights that
Jonah was in the belly of the whale and
he said so shall the son of man be in
the belly of the Earth for three days
and three nights and he was not in the
belly of the Earth for 3 days and three
nights he was only in the belly of the
Earth for 2 days and two nights okay so
it looks like
I know you skipped what I just said man
I don't know I I hope this is the last
time we can repeat this okay so you
you're talking about what he
specifically said and ignore what he
else what you know the other references
he says it he also specifically says he
spe he specifically says after 3 days so
does that mean on the fourth day he's
going to rise you have to take it all
into consideration we
got yes so you cannot deny the three
days and three nights take he details it
he details it details it with the three
days and the three nights my point he
details it with the three days he speaks
a general 3 days but then he says 3 days
and three let you speak go ahead so as
soon as you say we got to take all into
consideration what he says correct
that's the point so when we look at the
surrounding topic of when Jesus talks
about the duration of his death burial
and Resurrection corre it's when we look
at it all we see clearly that it's just
describing a 3-day time span after 3
days in 3 days on the third day 3 days
and three nights this is all what he
says so it's a euphemism it's not a eup
they're describing a three-day time SP
you even get this in um in in Esther in
Esther they talk about fasting for three
for
days in Esther they talk about fasting
for three days and three nights and then
they're going to go see the and she then
she's going to go see the king but it
says on the third day they finished
their fast the night didn't come so do
you see how even the Old Testament 3
days and three nights but on the third
day it shows a euphemism just describing
a 3-day time span that's biblical okay
but the the point is he specified nights
had he just said three days then that
would have been fine but because he said
three days and three nights and he
referenced a specific time of a specific
person who was in the belly of the whale
for exactly 3 days and three nights the
will spit him out on the third day on
the no after 3 days and three nights he
was in the Valley of the well for 3 days
and three nights so was it night time
that Jonah was spit out well we'd have
to go back and check it was on the third
day check it okay we'll check we'll
check it it's on the third it's on the
third day that he's that he was out he
was he wasn't in there another night he
no no no no he was was in the belly of
the whale for 3 days and three nights
then he was probably spit out at the end
of the 3 days and three nights whenever
that was but he was it was on the third
day that he was spit out well well I'll
have to I'll have to I'll have to check
that I'll have to check that so can we
agree to disagree here yeah we'll agree
to disagree on this sir oh my God logic
[Music]